[Musique]
georges recommencer
en
le spectacle est là ressemble davantage
à celui de l'alhambra parce que je suis
seul dans la fin pas seul je lis danser
avec moi le mans facile même genre de
spectacle avec à peu près 16 g c'est ce
numéro je t'en sais bien qu'il faut
chanter puis voilà et là je pense que si
tu te situes le portait tout petit peu
plus haut un peu plus court la salorge
les gens mais c'est plus joli là mais
c'est bien tu préfères pas le noir mais
très noir maintenant on va ici on va
essayer avec le on va essayer avec le
costume noir maintenant un rang démarre
toujours sur une idée de chanson pour
faire la chorégraphie ensuite mais il
est évident qu'il faut trouver pour
faire un tour de chant faut trouver un
équilibre
ce qui est très difficile parce que on
peut pas chanter toujours le même genre
de chansons il faut trouver des choses
différentes et c'est ça la difficulté
dans un tour de chant et là évidemment
ça m'a pris près d'un an
d'ailleurs pour j'ai fait beaucoup j'ai
demandé beaucoup à serge gainsbourg
parce que j'adore ce qu'il fait et j'ai
demandé à nougaro que je pense qu'aussi
béart qui m'a fait une chanson
et puis ça m'a appris tout ça m'a pris
quand même un an de préparation
ensuite bien
évidemment ça plaît à leur petit ou pas
si c'est lui fais toute la mise en scène
tous ont fait le choix des chansons
ensemble et puis ensuite bien ont choisi
certaines chansons qui correspondent à
un numéro je vous
ce super merde toujours quand elles le
font très lourd
je dis merde merde merde à l'amour c'est
fait
je dis merde mais
la merde à l'amour qui veut le bien de
la chanson de mai
b
[Musique]